this video is made possible either great
courses class an on-demand video
learning service learning your own pace
with no tests no schedules check out a
free trial from the great courses Plus
through the link in the description
below more on them in a bit
[Music]
today's protagonist is universally
recognized as one of the greatest
science fiction writers in the history
of literature he won the Hugo and nebula
awards among many others and is best
remembered as the inventor of robotics
the brilliant mind that conceived the
foundation series and the concept of
psychohistory during his long writing
career Isaac Asimov hopped back and
forth between science fiction and
mystery novels essays nonfiction
textbooks literary commentaries and
dissertations on humor he authored or
edited nearly 500 books in his lifetime
including an average of 10 or more
publications every year during his most
prolific production period he wrote on
Sherlock Holmes Shakespeare the Bible
the Romans the Greeks the universe he
almost wrote a musical with a Beatle if
you wanted to fill an entire day of your
life you could read all of just the
titles of his books but as entertaining
as a table of contents video would be
I'm gonna resist the temptation to
recite dozens of book names and do my
best to instead give you a quick
introduction to dr. Asimov's life the
main concepts behind his work and the
secrets that underpin his writing
techniques a baby boy called Isaac
Asimov was born to an array Trull Berman
and Judah Azam of Jewish family of
Miller's in the small village of
Petrovich II in modern-day Russia
sometime between October the 4th 1919
and January the second 1920 and could we
be more precise er well no actually we
can't even Asimov himself didn't know
his exact date of birth though he did
select the second of January as his
birthday so let's just go with that at
the age of 1 visualized and had to face
a lethal threat he and 16 other children
in his home
town developed severe pneumonia only he
survived two years later the toddler had
to go through another life-changing
event
longing for a better life Ana and Judah
took him and his younger sister by the
hands and immigrated to the United
States once the family relocated to
Brooklyn New York they adopted a more
Americanized spin on their name Asimov
the boy Isaac demonstrated signs of
vivacious intellect from very early on
by the age of five he was already fluent
in Yiddish his parents language as well
as English it also taught himself how to
read using the signs in the streets of
Brooklyn as his first reading material
and when he was seven he took
responsibility for teaching his youngest
sister how to read as well street signs
don't make for a very entertaining read
but luckily Isaac would soon graduate to
much better material Judah and Anna were
proud owners of a small general store
among other things they sold candy and
pulp fiction magazines and I really
can't think of a better environment for
a child to grow up in Judah had a strong
work ethic expecting everybody in the
family to help in the store Isaac was no
exception he woke up every morning
before 6:00 a.m. worked at the shop went
to school went back to the store and
spent hours there doing his homework as
well as helping his parents with their
business the upside was that he could
have access to an endless supply of
comic books and magazines with the ones
dedicated to science fiction being as
favorites spending time in the closed
confines of Judah's shop snacking on
candy and devouring sci-fi mags was
Isaac's idea of bliss at this stage he
did not dream of becoming a writer his
ambition was simply to operate a small
closed kiosk in the New York subway this
would mean he could spend his days
reading with the background hum of the
trains around the age of 11 Isaac began
to write his own stories but he still
kept them hidden from the world
in the meantime despite his harsh
routine which left little times at rest
and study Isaac thrived at school
excelling especially in scientific
subjects this progress was such that he
was able to skip three grades he
graduated from high school when he was
only fifteen the accelerated path
continued in higher education in 1939 he
was barely 19 at the time he graduated
from Columbia University with a Bachelor
of Science degree in chemistry
the subjects had not been his first pick
freshman Isaac had originally set his
sights on zoology and si may have done
very well in that field too however when
he discovered that he had to dissect an
alley cat for an assignment he switched
to a speciality in which he was only
required to handle molecules during his
years at Columbia Isaac had not
neglected his writing in June 1938 Isaac
had finished writing a story entitled
cosmic corkscrew and his father
encouraged him to submit it to John W
Campbell a greatly influential sci-fi
writer and editor of astounding science
fiction magazine delivering the story in
person via subway was 2 cents cheaper
than mailing it so Isaac did just that
to his surprise Campbell invited him
into his office to discuss the story two
days later Isaac received a rejection in
the post but it also came with an
encouraging note from Campbell Isaac
remains in touch with the editor and
with his guidance in March of 1939 he
succeeded in having one of his stories
professionally published for the first
time this story was marooned off festa
[Music]
in March of 1941 John W Campbell asked
Asimov an intriguing question what would
happen if the inhabitants of a planet
saw the Stars only once every thousand
years
Isaac used this idea as the basic plot
for the short story nightfall he didn't
know it yet but this was his first step
to a legendary literary status in 1968
the science fiction writers of America
voted nightfall as the best science
fiction story of the pre-1965
era no small feat for a 21 year old so
what exactly is so special about
nightfall to summarize the general plot
the story is about a planet lagash
bathed in the perpetual sunlight of six
stars for the first time in a thousand
years
an eclipse is predicted to darken the
skies so how will the population react
will they go insane will they burn down
their whole civilization while the
impending event creates raising tensions
between two groups of characters
scientists and cultists it's clear that
Asimov signs with the former who propose
rational solutions while the
superstitious cultists foretell of
heavenly fire that will rain down
- the dichotomy of science and religion
first emerging in nightfall became a
constant theme in Asimov's writings I've
never not for one moment been tempted
toward religion of any kind the fact is
I feel no spiritual void I have my
philosophy of life which does not
include any aspect of the supernatural
and which I find totally satisfying
nonetheless II never described himself
as an atheist considering it to be a
negative and defeatist label he
preferred to be called a humanist or
even better a rationalist Asimov always
maintains an open minded approach to
religion and even published extensive
guides to the old and new Testament
analyzing them from a secular historic
perspective by 1942
Isaac Asimov had been drafted into the
armed forces serving as a chemist at the
Naval Air Experimental Station in
Philadelphia the experience did not
hinder his creativity nor his compulsive
writing that year he completed and
published another seminal short story
runarounds which would revolutionize the
use of robots as characters in
literature the concept of artificial
beings can be traced back to early 19th
century masterpieces such as Mary
Shelley's Frankenstein or ETA Hoffman's
The Sandman
maybe even earlier Homer's Iliad
mentions that the god Hephaestus was
being served by maidens created out of
gold the word robot itself was first
used to by Czech playwright Karel Capek
in his Rossum's Universal robots Asimov
however was the first to introduce the
term robotics in runarounds and
subsequent works sentient robots endowed
with positronic brains regulated by the
Three Laws of Robotics number one a
robot may not injure a human being or
through inaction allow a human being to
come to harm - a robot must obey the
orders given it by human beings except
where such orders would conflict with
the first law 3 a robot must protect its
own existence as long as such protection
does not conflict with the first or
second laws a fourth or more precisely a
zeroeth law was later adopted by Asimov
0a robots may not harm humanity or by
inaction
our humanity to come to harm clearly
these imperatives are intended to
protect humanity from the threat of a
single robot rebelling or from a mass
uprising in his dozens of robot stories
and novels Asimov explores the
consequences of following these rules to
the extreme for example what would
happen if robots were to prevent humans
from doing anything at all in an effort
to protect them from potential harm the
big theme however is the consciousness
of the machines a sentient beings are
they really that different from humans
was Asimov simply studying the
implications of human consciousness
traps in a moral quandary perhaps this
is best explained by a recurring
character of the robotic story's Robo
psychologist dr. Susan Calvin in the
story evidence she is asked to evaluate
if electoral candidates Stephen Bailey
is a human or a humanoid robot bound by
the Three Laws Carbon admits this is not
possible as the three rules of robotics
are the essential guiding principles of
a good many of the world's ethical
systems she argues that every human
being is supposed to have the instinct
of self-preservation
that's law number three a good human
with a sense of responsibility will
defer to a proper authority or law
number two and every good person will
protect his fellow human beings
that's law number one Kelvin Asimov we
should say concludes by saying that any
being who follows these rules may be a
robot fans may simply be a very good man
now just before we get into the rest of
today's video I do want to take a moment
tell you about today's sponsor the great
courses plus now you can learn from the
world's best professors on the great
courses plus and if you're enjoying this
particular video I really think you'll
enjoy their course called science
fiction as philosophy obviously you can
see why that's pretty relevant to what
we're covering today that course touches
on a whole lot of things related to
sci-fi and indeed Asimov for example
there's a solid section all about the
dangers of AI where it
heading in the future it's a great watch
like really all of the lectures on the
great courses plus ah basically its
university education it's at your own
pace there are no tests there are no
schedules and it's super easy to access
you can do it on your PC tablet phone
whatever you like they've also got audio
streaming so you don't have to sit there
and watch if you don't want it you can
plug in while you're on the move I
commute to work so often I'll just give
that a listen super easy to use in their
app there's also thousands of lectures
to choose from so you know if that's
science science a philosophy one doesn't
apply appeal to you you're gonna find
something so it's great stuff you can
try it for free there's a link below or
just go to the great courses plus com
forward slash buyer graphics that helps
support what we're doing here and let's
get back to the show in the meantime
Asimov had also managed to tie the knot
with Gertrude blue gurmann on July the
26th 1942 the couple had two children
David and Robin Joan after the ends of
World War two Asimov was transferred
from the Navy to an army base in Oahu
Hawaii which meant yet to face his
greatest fear
flying taken to the skies was something
he did only twice in his life as Isaac
preferred to treat himself to cruise
ships when traveling abroad after his
honorable discharge at the end of 1946
Isaac returned to his studies earning a
PhD in chemistry at Columbia University
in 1948 his income from writing was not
yet enough to sustain a family so in
1949 he accepted an offer from Boston
University's School of Medicine to teach
biochemistry 20 years later he confessed
in an interview that I didn't feel
compelled to tell them that I'd never
had any biochemistry and yet somehow me
managed the teachers not only that he
started writing textbooks about
biochemistry
it was while writing one such book in
1951 that he finally realized that all
he really wanted to do was write the
year 1951 approved significance and not
just because of this epiphany that was
also when one of his manuscripts was
published as the novel foundation
followed by Foundation and Empire in
1952 and second foundation in 1953 the
original trilogy was later expanded with
for further prequels and sequels Asimov
himself acknowledged it would
his most enduring visa fiction I'm
criminally oversimplifying now but the
series is about the decline of a
Galactic Empire after a rule of 12,000
years mathematician Hari Seldon has
created a new science called psycho
history the use of mathematical modeling
to analyze the aggregate behavioral data
of an enormous number of people
this can help deduce the patterns of
behavior of the masses essentially
Seldon is able to predict the Empire's
future one marked by a dark age of
ignorance and warfare that will last
thirty thousand years to protect
mankind's knowledge Selden gathers the
best minds of the Empire to a remote
planet a sanctuary which he calls the
foundation over the course of centuries
the foundation will expand rivaling the
decaying Empire according to a master
plan set in motion by Selden the series
is incredibly complex spanning a
thousands of years and dealing with
ambitious themes such as the
preservation of knowledge the
immortality of mankind via the
propagation of ideas and the
manipulation of the masses through
religion in 1966 the foundation series
won a special Hugo Award for best
all-time series in fantasy and science
fiction snatching the prize from none
other than the Lord of the Rings by JRR
Tolkien fans of both series do feel free
to argue in the comments below so far I
have barely mentioned a fraction of
Isaac Asimov's body of work the man was
renowned for being incredibly prolific
and he improved with age yeah some fun
stats compiled by the New York Times
Asimov wrote his first 100 books over
the 20-year period spanning from the
publication of his first short story
until October 1959 his second batch of a
hundred books took him about nine and a
half years yet doubled his rate and he
kept accelerating his third run of 100
books took him only 69 months or less
than six years so one may wonder did he
ever suffer from writer's block or what
was his secret while it's a pity that
Asimov never published a book about
writing we can glean the secret of his
success from a series of interviews and
articles that he released it boils down
to a mixture of genetics and good habits
Asimov remarks that I have been
fortunate to be born
with a restless and efficient brain with
a capacity of a clear thought and an
ability to put that thought into words
none of this is to my credit I am the
beneficiary of a lucky break in the
genetic sweepstakes as per the good
habits Asimov woke up every morning at
6:00 a.m. sat down to the typewriter by
7:30 and worked without stopping until
10:00 p.m. he never wrote more than two
drafts of a piece of work this was a
self-imposed restriction to avoid
lingering for too long on a piece that
he enjoyed particularly but those who
dabble in writing know very well that
the toughest bit can be just to start
writing Asimov never had such a problem
when asked if he had some form of
concentration ritual to prepare him for
his writing he replied before I can
possibly begin writing it is always
necessary for me to turn on my electric
typewriter and to get close enough to it
so that my fingers can reach the keys
and once he started he just kept on
going although he never really stumbled
on a creative block that Asimov admitted
to getting bored with the work at hand
in that case his advice was simple keep
a number of open projects at hands and
immediately start writing about
something else regarding style the
author's advice was to keep things
simple I make no efforts to write
poetically or in a high literary style I
try only to write clearly I never read
Hemingway or Fitzgerald or Joyce or
Kafka to this day I am a stranger to
20th century fiction and poetry and I
have no doubt that it shows in my
writing despite avoiding the Giants of
20th century literature Isaac Asimov was
a voracious reader and learner
encouraging would-be writers to never
stop accumulating knowledge especially
beyond a traditional school curriculum
so over the 1950s and 1960s Asimov was
cranking through his first 100 books and
his career was soaring but of course
this left little to no time to his
family by his own admission he dedicated
little attention to his children and
while he later recovered his
relationship with his youngest daughter
Robin his rapport with his eldest son
David was always strained David grew up
to become a troubled and isolated
individual he achieved some notoriety in
1998 after being arrested on charges of
possession of child pornography but back
to Asimov in the 1950s his marriage to
Gertrude was deteriorating in his
memoirs Asimov did not pinpoint a
specific
reason for their drifting apart he
blames in part his wife's smoking habit
and even her rheumatoid arthritis but in
the end he had to admit that it was the
slow and natural process by which
annoyances multiply and frictions come
slowly to seem irreconcilable eventually
the couple fell apart and formally
separated in 1970
now while Asimov was happily married to
Gertrude he was described as being a
model of moral rectitude by his friends
and fellow sci-fi author Fredrick Paul
about the same poll noted that as soon
as the crack started appearing in the
couple's life Asimov gave in to some
unwholesome behavior to say the least
during the frequent sci-fi conventions
he attended from the late 1950s to the
late 1960s Asimov developed a reputation
being something of a sex pest in plain
terms he had an obsession with groping
the backsides of young and pretty
participants at said conventions
he was so renowned for his unwanted
advances that in 1962 he was even
invited to give a semi serious talk at
the world science fiction convention on
the positive power of posterior pinching
he tentatively accepted the invitation
replying I have no doubt I could give a
stimulating talk that would stiffen the
manly fiber of everyone in the audience
I will have to ask permission of various
people who are or would be concerns in
the matter if they say no it will be no
all of this sounds like it was from a
different era in which such behavior was
somehow widely accepted condones and
perhaps even laughed about at least from
that's what we learned from madmen
however even then it was not a given
that a young lady should tolerate
unwanted physical attention from an
older dude who was in a position of
power Frederic Paul clearly equips with
a stronger moral compass confronted
Asimov about his bad habits to which his
friend admitted that he did get slapped
a loss and deservedly so
besides these incidents literary
conventions also provided Asimov with an
opportunity for meaningful human contact
back in 1956 it was at one of these
events where Isaac struck up a
friendship with psychiatrist Janet
Jetson fan of his writing their
friendship continued by correspondence
over the next decade after as Marvin
Gertrude separated Janet
helped him find a flat in New York
conveniently just a few blocks from our
own the two started dating soon after
the movement it eventually evolved into
a serious relationship
when Asimov's divorce was finalized in
1973 he and Janet were married only two
weeks later the marriage was a happy one
by all accounts and the two frequently
collaborated generate sci-fi novels for
children and Isaac worked as a redditor
[Music]
most of Asimov's work during the 1960s
and early 1970s was dedicated to
nonfiction writing including school
textbooks essays on shakespeare ancient
Romans ancient Greeks and the Bible due
to his status as an author and scientist
he was frequently consulted about his
vision for the future of humanity in
1964 he published an article in The New
York Times titled visit to the World's
Fair of 2014 in which she gave some
predictions on the next 50 years of
human progress he correctly anticipated
the market entry of self-driving cars
video calls the widespread use of
nuclear power and simple robots that
performed household tasks Asimov also
voiced his concerns about overpopulation
estimating the Earth's inhabitants could
number as many as 6.5 billion by 2014 it
was actually 7.1 billion so he wasn't
far off other predictions were a bit
more off the mark
for example his expectation that
underwater and underground housing would
become the norm or that transport would
happen with hovercraft like machines
finally he prophesized that humanity
would begin suffering from the disease
of boredom as a consequence of Robotics
supplanting most of our jobs maybe not a
reality by 2014 but definitely a
consideration for a not-too-distant
future I mean soon enough you'll
probably just be watching deep fake
simon for in the mid 1970s to the 1980s
Asimov returned to science fiction with
a vengeance writing for additional
sequels to his magnum opus the
foundation in these sequels Asimov
manages to tie the events of the
foundation with those narrated in his
robot series which in that continuty
happens thousands of years previously in
this way he creates an overarching macro
plot of celestial magnitude in 1974
Asimov
disto into a genre completely alien to
him musicals the initiative came from
former Beatle Paul McCartney who
approached Asimov with an idea for a
musical movie a plotter devised by Paul
was that a band discovered they were
being impersonated by a group of
extraterrestrials Asimov expanded it
into an idea called five and five and
one in this story parasitic aliens crash
on earth and a searching for hosts to
invade after trying out lizards cattle
and eagles they decide to inhabit a
group of musicians the Beatles McCartney
hated this whole new storyline moreover
Asimov had ditched the dialogue written
by the musician the two potential
co-authors parted way and the few pages
that exist wait to be rediscovered as
the Howard gotleib archives of Boston
University in his later years
Isaac Asimov suffered from the onset of
chronic heart disease which required him
to undertake a triple bypass in 1983
even though he recovered quite well his
health gradually declined over the
following decade on April the 6th 1992
Isaac Asimov died in New York reportedly
due to heart and kidney failure at least
this was the official version maintained
by his brother Stanley and by the New
York Times obituary only in 2002 did the
real truth emerge after the 1983
operation Isaac had received a
transfusion of infected blood
contracting HIV and eventually dying of
AIDS it is easy to quantify Isaac
Asimov's legacy today through the sheer
volume of books articles and adaptations
of his work an asteroid and crater on
Mars have even been named after him but
he also left a legacy that is less
quantifiable and inspiration towards the
accumulation and preservation of
knowledge weapon of empowerment against
ignorance and superstition there is a
cult of ignorance in the United States
and there always has been he said and I
think well personally out here that
that's not just the United States Asimov
warned us and will finish on this the
strain of anti-intellectualism has been
a constant threat winding its way
through our political and cultural life
nurtured by the false notion that
democracy means that my ignorance
is just as good as your knowledge so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that like button below and do check out
our fantastic sponsor the great courses
plus so I'm going to link to below you
can try them for free which is fantastic
a great way to expand your knowledge
beyond what you learned in this video
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]